[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez ou de la
police pas grand chose
oui si vous avez ce sentiment d'être
protégés harper a pas pas du tout seul
tour pour l avant est ce qu'on l'a
reproché aux policiers
je ne pense rien mais je les laisse
tranquilles je les fréquente pas moi je
suis pour la police et est au combat il
en faudrait davantage
moi je suis étranger oui alors des fois
je suis embêté par la police elle fait
peur parce que tout citoyen un certain
moment de sa vie a commis l'infraction
aussi minime soit elle et lorsqu'il se
trouve en présence d'un policier il se
trouve en présence de celui qui est
chargé de la remarque et de la relever
et il peut toujours se demander si ce
policier ne la connais pas alors ma foi
et vaut mieux ne pas avoir de contact
avec le policier c'est toujours
dangereux
a priori on dit qu'elle est violente est
ce que c'est votre avis pas pour moi pas
pour le moment je n'ai pas eu à faire
avec elle c'est pas mon avis du tout du
tout au contraire ils ne sont peut-être
pas assez dans certains cas je pense que
justement elle pourrait très bien être
même plus énergiques pour les trieurs et
quand on a vu les obsèques tous les
tyrans carré les 2 300 personnes qui
étaient derrière ce corbillard plein de
fleurs parce qu'on avait pas c'était un
truc c'était un honnête homme il
rappelle un corbillard avec tant de
fleurs
on a accusé la police
très exactement la brigade antigang de
brutalité de racisme et c'est vrai que
certains ont même mis en cause des
méthodes qu'elle est qu'elle emploie il
m'apparaît utile de dire tout d'abord
que l'organisation que je représente
s'est toujours prononcé de la manière la
plus nette contre les brutalités
policières et contre le racisme et nous
approuvons totalement le ministre de
l'intérieur et le préfet de police qui
ont déclaré que si des fautes avaient
été commises elles seraient sanctionnés
il est temps que la police s'adapte aux
méthodes des assassins du 20e siècle
ça n'est pas encore le cas mais cela dit
la police a encore le moral
tout simplement parce que le métier que
nous avons choisi nous le connaissions
tel qu'il est nous sommes là pour mettre
hors d'état de nuire des individus
dangereux
toutefois devant le déferlement des
attaques qui sont portées contre la
police
il arrive que les policiers soient là de
servir à la fois de bouc émissaire et de
rempart à une société qui le plus
souvent s'en moque des policiers qui
sont là aussi je ne le cache pas de
passer leur temps à risquer leur peau
pour mettre en prison des individus
dangereux alors que d'autres s'ingénie à
les en faire sortir
qu'est-ce que vous accusez je n'accuse
personne
je constate et je pense que c'est à la
population d'en tirer les conclusions